so I have some very exciting news for you
I'm back a new film profile made
after the fujifilm eterna simulation
I've been pretty busy lately, and had very little
time on hand, but I really wanted to make this
video to share with you these settings and how you
can use the creative LUTs to get the same look.
Also, i will show you how to replicate the
cinestill800t look, so watch the
whole video to find out how.
So, a little bit about the profile
I'm absolutely in love with this profile,
it's just gorgeous in terms of
contrast and how it renders colors.
Been testing it for a week or two in multiple
scenarios and lighting conditions and it's just
crazy good. last weekend i was at a party and
took a bunch of pictures with this profile
the colors were so good i felt no need to edit
them, so i've just sent out the jpegs.
It handles underexposing and
overexposing very very well,
with soft gradations and pleasing colors.
With most of my previous film profiles,
i like to keep the image a little bit
underexposed, but this profile is so
versatile and can be exposed both ways.
My only complaint with this profile is that
it shift the yellow towards green very
much when overexposed and s ometimes
can give wierd hues in the highlights in some
situations. This is caused by the cine4 gamma.
generally that's the reason wh y i usually avoided
using cine4, if you have watched my other video
on Film Simulation for sony cameras, you can
notice none of the film profile that i've made
is based on cine4, but this time i needed a
more contrasty cine gamma for this profile.
Also cine4 is probably the noisiest from all
cine gammas, it's not a big issue if you enjoy
the grain, but for the cleanest image i wouldstill
use cine1 and it's good to keep that in mind.
As a reference, in this video the max
iso used was 2500 with a f2.8 lens.
Many of you asked for a tutorial on how to shoot
these film profiles to get a similar look, i'm
currently working on a video explaining general
rules or settings on how i shoot each profile and
i hope to finish it next week.
Subscribe to be notified about
that video when it comes out.
so now, let's get the cinestill look
This is the raw footage from the
camera, shot on the eterna film profile.
and graded using the creative luts pack
to get even closer to the film look
All you have to do is choose a halation
strenght from the Creative lut folder
and apply it to the footage
Is that easy
To adjust the halation effect just right
click on the node, open the compound node
and on this layer adjust the red curve
to limit or extend the affected area
you can find these on my
website, link down bellow
You can see it looks really
good out of the camera
and it's saving me a lot of time that
i would've spent on color grading
the way you can achieve this cold cyan
color is by shooting bellow 2500k
If you shoot sony, you know the minimum
kelvin you can choose manually is 2500,
bbut if you make a custom white
balance you can actually go even lower
o higher than manual limits and
i'll show you how you can do that
go into the color temperature menu, you can do
that by going into the photo icon at page 12,
but i reccommend assigning it to a button, so
it's one step away in any given situation
I assigned this menu to the joystick just by
clicking so i can easily access it at any time,
that is a life saver in many occassions.
scroll down to the custom balance,
press ok and now find something yellow
and fill the whole screen with it
press ok again
now the camera will try
to correct the yellow tint in the image and
will compansate by going under 2500 kelvin
save this color as a custom, you can create 3
of these custom colors and trust me they are
very helpful, not only for film colors but for
day to day shooting, so use this function
I've also saved a creative lut for footage
that is shot at regular kelvin so you can
just drag and drop it on any footage
together with all the Original Grades
that i've used for the Initial video.
Make sure to check them out and hit the
like button if you like this Eterna Profile
to save this simulation, go in the menu and find
picture profile, on the a7iii is at
page 12 in the image icon. hit ok,
press right to enter the menu and there you
can find all the settings that you need
The settings to this profile are free,
but testing, creating these profiles
and editing the videos take a lot of time, so
please consider supporting the channel by buying
the Creative Luts or by buying me a coffee
I appreciate your support, that's why for the
next month the luts will be 50% off
Like and Subscribe if you haven't already
Thanks again for watching, and
see you soon